何か気分が上がらへん
うん…
そうゆう日も
あるよね”
う”う”ゲホゲホ（咳）
う”しぬ”しぬ”
すみません（汗）
こんにちははじめしゃちょーです
えーーーーーーーーーーーー
５日ぶりに静岡にかえってきました
大変でした。。大変でしたというか
静岡に帰ってこれないこと自体もつらかったし
まあ東京で今回何してたかというとまあいろんな撮影をしつつ
あのポケモンの竜王戦っていうのに出てたんですよボクスペシャルゲストとして
で、竜王戦ってどんなのかっていうと
そのポケモンのゲーム、あの…
ポケモンのゲームと、ポケモンのカードゲームで
あの、日本一強い人を決めるみたいな大会なんですけど
それで僕特別ゲストとして出ることが決まってから
ホントにめちゃくちゃポケモン実はやってまして
だってあれあれですよあの
竜王戦ってもうほんとにそこら辺の素人とかなんかちょっと強いような人が出ても全く勝てないんですよ
めっちゃ強すぎて、周りが
その中ボク、まあ約一か月くらいかな、一か月ぐらいホントに
多分動画以外の時間はほぼポケモンしかしてなかったです
それくらいポケモンに時間を割くことで
なんとか。。。竜王戦。。。
1勝できました（おめでとう！はじめん）
はい、良かったですホントに良かった。
奇跡的に勝利をつかめたので良かったです
っというはなしをしたいんじゃなくて！！
ずーっとポケモンをやってたり、対戦してなんかいろいろ勉強したりしてました
やー楽しかったです
はい！っというわけで今日の動画は、ごめんなさいちょっと帰ってきたばっかりでホント何もないんで
開ける暇がなくて開けられなかったんですけど
こちらぁ！「ナノユニバース」
「ナノユニバース」ってね、あれなんすよね
何か僕の勝手なイメージなんですけどすごい服がたけぇなってイメージのお店があるんですけど
そこの福袋を買いました！
いやもうほんとにあの。。。
自分へのご褒美です
お値段が￥１５０００です
ヤバイ。。。皆さんご存知の通りボク服売りすぎて今服がないんで
何でもいいからなんか服が欲しいってことでちょっと買いました
「ナノユニバース」ってホントにおしゃれでかっこいいんですけど高いんで
こうゆう福袋でしか買いたくねぇなって気持ちがあっったんで今回買わせていただきました
タグ（ブチィ）
で何かボクボクの勝手な
あ”いたぁ！！！
ボクの勝手な想像なんですけど、ボク福袋って普段買わないんですよ
なぜかというと、なんで福袋ってある…んだと思います？
はい！その通りなんすよ
「売れ残り」なんですよ
いや知らないんですけどね
その年末までに売れ残ったものを「やべっ！やべー」お店の人が「やべー」つって
こう、何とかこうみんなでこう「おらおらぁ」って売るために作られたのが福袋だってボク勝手に思ってるんで
この中にもきっと売れ残りがあるのではないでしょうかぁ？
まあこれでかっこいいのがあれば「マジサイコー」って感じなんですけど
無かったときはもうショックですわな
タグ（ブチィ）いたぁ！！！
ハッハ！ヒッヒッヒッヒ！！
服の…洋服のタグが怖すぎる…
じゃあ開けていきます！
あーすごいめっちゃ服はいってるヤバイ
ただホント「ナノユニバース」はかっこいいんで
かっこいい服。。。
期待してるぜ
じゃ、まずは
これだあああ！！！
は。。。
ワーワーワーワーワーワー待ってこれ勝確じゃん
普通におしゃれな何かセーターなんですけどお
やった！やった！やった！
え？福袋ってこんなに良かったっけ？やった！
ありがとうございます！
やった！やった！やった！何か普通に何かわりぃわりぃわりぃな～
いや、ほんと申し訳ないくらい売れ残りとか言ったんですけどめちゃくちゃいいですよこれ
え？「ナノユニバース」最高か！？
え、待って待ってほんとに、嬉しいな
次は。。。
これだあああああ！！！
は？！
おーおーおーおーおーわ、チェック柄のシャツですね
いや、全然アリ
フムフムフムフムホーホーホーホー
なんか。。。
ヲタクみたいになっちゃった
はいでは次いきましょう
やはりいろんな服のバリエーションがあるというのはとてもいいことなのでとても楽しみですね
どうなってんだこれ
これだああああ！
うお！は！
なんだこれは、へ？なにこれ
シャカシャカ生地だな
「ナノユニバース」なら絶対かっこいいことは間違いないと思ってるんで
こうゆうアウターっぽいです
着てみましょう！！！
わあああ！なんか、いそう
なんか全然ヲタク感なくなったなこうすることによって
やった↑これいいやつしか入ってないじゃん
これラストかな？はいこれラストです！
わ、かっこいいかっこいいかっこいい
これロング丈のやつや！！
あざー
これはもうあざすとしか言いようがないっすね
しっくりきちゃってる気がするんですけど
これロング丈のこのねこのちょっとこのちょっと長い感じが好きなんすよね
ただ黒っ。
普通に15,000円以上の買い物はしてる感はある
いやホントに何か久しぶりに5日間東京行ってめちゃくちゃ疲れたんですけど
まあこれで頑張った分しばらく東京に行かなくてよくなったんで
静岡でゆっくり動画が作っていければいいなと思っております！
「ナノユニバース」
ええな！
じゃあな！
んぺんぺんぺんぺんぺんぺんぺんぺ♪
ぺーぺぺぺぺーぺーぺぺぺぺーぺぺぺぺぺぺーぺぺぺぺーぺーぺぺぺぺぺぺぺんぺんぺんぺんぺ
デデデデン♪